do you know how the video start how how
your videos start yet yes
good morning John pick up dog brother
what are you have you ever go start we
do way to cast out the jump what am i
have to music I'll make one for you dog
brother the great thing is that I'm
going to put that in as the intro and
then we're going to have that
conversation that sounds good I love it
so people have suggested things that we
should do together and questions we
should ask each other okay I start with
this question would you rather have a
butt for a face or a face for a but wait
so if I have a face for a but does that
mean I have a butt for a numb and I just
would have used venture faces to face up
face to face face well obviously I was
lying area to raise two faces because
they need to eat you had a butt face you
would eat through the butt and poop
through your other but no I'm saying you
would poop out but the button would
wouldn't have any teeth what it with the
butt hefty and I think it'd just be
smoothies no I mean what the thing is no
one ever sees your butt so you don't
have to know like you would have to sit
on it let's do a suggestion for an
activity okay zero efficiency says high
really high from a camera yeah Jessica
wants us to play one word historic you
know about it yes we just we make a
story with one word a time yeah but big
giant had money so he decided to make
more dogs LexA basically hood monkeys in
mother Hubbard's Auntie that says ygal a
punch competition I think probably means
Eagle if you have an eagle in here oh
there's all over the place oh there's
what but come on now was the competition
gonna get a lot I don't know who won but
I'll find out what I'm editing okay
Aaron Joseph says high five using feet
oh well just yeah oh okay yeah Wow
that'll happen to satisfy ah
we're 36 year old man our lips we
Chuck's this we should clone ourselves
I've always wanted to get punched by it
Weezy clones
I'll go get a Wii club for you okay okay
hello I'm a clone of wheezy waiter Ricca
this edit really easy for me better
which means you're ready to be punched I
think I'm ready up file my dreams are
coming true good
Phoenix wants us to screen for four
minutes which is the thing that I feel
like doing anyway after this
okay alright three two one
[Applause]
Michael wants us to kiss we did it they
did it Lucy says make old man noises I
think that this is the main old man
noise well Sam go I don't know why you
feel the need to tighten up when you're
stacked so I can talk normal while
standing up or sitting down but
sometimes I will actually like this look
like ah dad comes here not pooping right
that soon he says pillow fight ah
Michael Ron to suggest a day in the life
of Orrin green starring Hank green is
dead and Craig benzine has baby hey
Craig thanks for joining me on this
exceptionally weird episode of
vlogbrothers in which I distract myself
from the current state of the world
you're welcome I'm here for you Hank and
thanks for letting me be here instead of
you know probably in a gutter somewhere
where I'd be he might be in a hotel room
changing pants you saying my pants are
dirty well thanks for joining us what do
we say at the end of the videos John
I'll see you on Tuesday
did you wink I did yeah thanks Greg you
could click over here maybe to go to his
YouTube channel it's good stuff and he's
going to be at nerdcon nerdfighteria in
Boston February 25th and 26th that was
fun there's a longer version of this
video also on Hanks channel